the liberal media screws up again
president Trump demanding NBC fire
anchor Chuck Todd after his show Meet
the Press deceptively edited Attorney
General Bill bars remarks on general
Flynn watch well history is written by
the winners so it's largely depends on
who's writing the history I was struck
Peggy by the cynicism of the answer it's
a correct answer but he's the Attorney
General he didn't make the case that he
was upholding the rule of law
he was almost admitting that yeah this
is a this is a political job but here's
bill bars full response well history is
written by the winners so it's largely
depends on who's writing the history but
I think a fair history would say it was
it was a good decision because it upheld
the rule of law
NBC later apologized for the dishonest
editing on Twitter so Juan Williams
you've got some journalistic chops
you know Meet the Press the pristine
Meet the Press on Sunday for NBC how bad
is this it's bad they made a mistake I
don't think there's any question about
that I think if you listen to the full
statement made by the Attorney General
he clearly says it was about upholding
the rule of law in his opinion but
here's the thing Jesse they acknowledged
the mistake and then they corrected it
and we all make mistakes in the business
of journalism I think the problem comes
in when people either try to deny it or
try to hide it and in this case NBC
didn't either they admitted it and they
owned up to it so to my mind what I get
troubled by is the idea that and I think
you said this to me last week you said
hey you know what history no winners
write their history ok and even if you
think that in the current writing under
Bill Barr that somehow justice has been
upheld I think it's important to note
that in the when it comes to matters of
law what happens when people testify
when they admit to guilt in court twice
on two occasions it matters no matter if
you're the winner or loser facts
admissions of guilt should matter as
should evidence introduced but
apparently that didn't matter to a man
who was supposed to run our justice
system well I think it was Obama's own
AG Eric Holder that dismissed a case of
perjury against a Republican senator mr.
Stephens but that's neither here nor
there Greg Vaughn says this is a mistake
but all of these mistakes keep making
the president look bad so is it really a
mistake again yeah they all go in the
same direction silly it's true the media
everybody makes mistakes we can forgive
that but when they uniformly go in one
direction something's wrong so when
people gripe about Trump being obsessed
with the media he's only doing the job
that the media won't do you know they
don't actually Polly like I I would they
have apologized if they weren't caught
and I'm wondering it's a part of the
great thing about social media is that
there's a lot of little police officers
out there who have had it who see that
the media is broken and are holding
their feet to the fire I personally
think Chuck Todd has blood on his hands
that's what he said Mary said that Tim
Russert would never make a mistake yeah
yes he suggested Trump had blood on his
hands what last week so he did you know
tit for tat Dagan four years of peddling
a phony Russia collusion fable and now
some networks like we're not even
talking about it let's move on move on
why are you talking about the Flint days
I can't believe they're trying to help
my mother always used to ask what are
those people of those other networks
always look like they're smelling
something
well it's mom I can say definitively to
her now it's because they've been
hacking up for years a bunch of hot
garbage and the air must be rancid and
we'll finish with you Dana it looks like
this interview was done on Thursday with
CBS in babar and on Sunday Meet the
Press ran it so that's three days they
had to make sure this was right yeah
yeah to Greg's point about social media
it's like all these people out there
able to make citizens arrests now over
the Internet if you they see something
wrong and I don't think no I don't think
in NBC would have apologized if they had
been called out for it I do think though
that somebody I feel bad for peggy
noonan
i know Peggy I haven't talked to her
about this but what a position to put
her in you have you're the anchor of the
show and your producers put your
contributor in a position like that
that's really wrong as well and I would
imagine she probably wasn't too happy
either yeah he really set her up and I
checked and the fives ratings are better
than meet the presses by almost a
million viewers just wanted to make sure
everybody knew that and we're on cable